إنتاجات الميزانية الكبيرة أفضل المواهب في هوليوود
متوفرة فقط على هاتفك
وأعتقد أنها أكبر فكرة أننا
فعلنا هذه الفكرة على الإطلاق وهي عبارة عن منصة دفق فيديو للجوال فقط
تسمى kwibi
باختصار للبايتات السريعة ، ما نحاول القيام به
هو جمع أفضل
هوليوود وأفضل ما في وادي السيليكون ،
محتوى رائع للغاية مع
تقنية مبتكرة لجعل مشاهدة الفيديو على هاتفك
المحمول غير عادي ،
ستقدم الخدمة برمجة أصلية عالية الإنتاج
في حلقات لا تزيد عن
10 دقائق وستكون قادرًا على
مشاهدة العروض التي تحمل هاتفك
ينفق kwibi رأسيًا أو أفقيًا
مليار دولار على المحتوى في العام الأول
الذي تراهن فيه جيفري على
اختيار جعل هذا النظام الأساسي للجوّال فقط ،
فلماذا تعتقد أن الأشخاص
سيدفعون مقابل مشاهدة المحتوى حصريًا على
هواتفهم  نصف
مليار شخص يتجولون مع هذه
التلفزيونات في جيوبهم
يشاهدون بالفعل مليار ساعة من
المحتوى كل يوم أعرفه للتو
سيعمل المديرون التنفيذيون وراء kwibi
بالفعل عمالقة والتكنولوجيا والإعلام
وكان ويتمان الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة eBay
وشارك هيوليت باكارد كاتزنبرج في تأسيس DreamWorks
Animation وكان رئيسًا
لاستوديوهات ديزني الآن وهم يراهنون على أن
الناس سيصرفون 5 دولارات شهريًا مقابل
فيديو قصير على الهاتف المحمول فقط ويأتي في
وقت يزداد فيه ازدحام مساحة دفق الفيديو ،
حيث
يبحث الناس عن ميزانياتهم أكثر
فأكثر هنا في جورجيا ،
ولا يزال الكثير
منهم يشتركون في خدمات مثل HBO
Netflix Hulu Spotify لن
يكون الأمر كما لو أن الناس فجأة لديهم أموال أكثر
وسيقولون فقط 5.00 دولارات آه
كل ما يخبرنا به المستهلك العادي
أنهم يريدون إنفاق حوالي 40 دولارًا شهريًا على
بعض هذه الخدمات ، لذلك ليس هناك
الكثير من  النمو هنا بالضرورة من
المحفظة تنفق على أساس شهري ، لكن
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة kwibi يقول إنهم طوروا محتوى
مختلفًا عن أي شيء في السوق ، وعادة
ما تكون في المنزل تشاهده في المقدمة  من التليفزيون
يلتزم حقًا بمدة نصف ساعة على الأقل
للدخول في عرض ، نحن نذهب
بعد وقت مختلف من اليوم تستيقظ فيه
في الصباح ، فربما تكون في
موقف التنقل في طابور لتناول فنجان من
القهوة إذا كان لديك  موعدًا مع الطبيب ،
لديك كل
هذه اللحظات
التي تلعب فيها ألعابًا غير رسمية ، ربما
تقوم بعمل شبكات اجتماعية ، وسنقدم
لك شيئًا مختلفًا يكون
المحتوى المميز مكلفًا للغاية
، ومن غير الواضح ما إذا كان الجمهور
يريده بهذا الشكل.  يقدم الرجال
إنتاجات ماركيز بفيلم روائي طويل
مثل الجودة ، حيث تنفق مائة
ألف دولار في الدقيقة ، وهو ما
يشبه نوعًا ما في مجموعة Game of
Thrones ، كيف يمكن للمشاهدين
تقدير جودة إنتاجهم حقًا
على شاشة صغيرة جدًا.
أصبحت في الواقع
لحظة اتصال حميمة شخصية للغاية تضع فيها
سماعات الأذن لديك ولديك صلة
بهذا المحتوى
المذهل حقًا ترى أن الجمهور الأصغر هو
فعلاً  أنا مسرور بهذه التجربة
ولا أعتقد أنه يمكنك الإفراط في
الإنتاج لهم ، أعتقد أنهم سيقدرون
امتلاك أفضل المواهب
ورواية القصص الرائعة يا رفاق ، حيث أن ستيفن
سبيلبرغ يقدم لك سلسلة رعب من
أجلك ، حيث تستضيف جينيفر لوبيز
عرضًا واقعيًا تفعله  أنت قلق من أنك
تضع الشريط عالياً للغاية لدرجة أنك
تقوم بالكثير من العمل بعيدًا عن البوابة على
الإطلاق ، فليس هناك أشياء
كانت أساسية بالنسبة لميج وأنا
منذ اللحظة التي التقينا فيها وقلنا
لنذهب لتسلق قمة إيفرست كل يوم  استيقظ
وفكر في من هو جمهورك ،
فما الذي سيسعدهم وإذا كان
بإمكاننا إخبارهم بقصص رائعة إذا كان بإمكاننا
توفير الراحة لهم في هذا ، فهذه
هي الأشياء التي ستجعلنا
ناجحين
[موسيقى]